so anecdotally I went to Burning Man and
there's there's at the end of The
Burning Man week you there's the temple
that everyone like puts their their old
thoughts and feelings they all like
notes from dead loved ones things they
want to like let go of and grieve over
they put him in the temple and the
temple the energy at the temple when you
go to the temple is just like siphoning
up and it's just it was tough to get
near that place and I was tripping so it
could be I could be out of my mind but I
think there might be something too like
honing energy into physical objects
complete anecdotal nonsense of course
religions from time immemorial talk
about it you know imbuing uh an idol and
things like that and cultures have
sacrificed children to the weather yep
for Millennia yep I think people are
known to have called lightning is that
like what if like it turns out that you
actually do have to sacrifice your kids
to to Malik to stop the weather from
going back but I'll tell you stranger
things stranger things are happening
around